the Samsung's new Galaxy s23 destroy the
iPhone 14 well I'm gonna find out in
this video by comparing everything
including the designs the displays the
cameras the performance the ports
everything now it makes this comparison
really simple is the price they're both
800 and they both start at 128 gigs of
storage however it looks like the s23
does get some extras for example it has
an extra camera on the back which the
iPhone 14 does not have that's one of
the biggest downsides so that's going to
be a big deal when we get into the
camera comparison now in terms of the
design I love what Samsung did with the
s23 I love how everything is flat the
glass on the back the glass on the front
flat just like the iPhone 14 however
they kind of gave a nice little curve to
the sides the actual frame so it feels
really nice and grippy in your hands
compared to the completely flat sides on
the 14. I also like how they have the
buttons all on one side so volume rocker
right here and the power button right
next to it compared to the iPhone which
it has on the other side which is a
little bit harder to to change the
volume if you're right-handed and of
course we have the USBC port on the s23
which is awesome compared to the
lighting which is going to be dead as
soon as the iPhone 15. now probably the
worst thing about the iPhone 14 is the
notch that is still here super annoying
compared to this really really nice hole
punch really Slim and of course the
notch is there because of face ID which
I personally prefer because look at that
as soon as you open it it just
automatically unlocks it super
convenient very very nice compared to
fingerprint scanner on the s23 which is
also very nice and snappy but it's just
not as good as face ID now before we get
into the huge display differences I've
got to tell you about today's sponsor
the one inch wallet for your iPhone
which is a crypto wallet that's not like
the others out there where you're
risking your crypto this one is
non-custodial which means it's safe and
secure because they don't own your
crypto in their exchange it's actually
stored on your your own personal wallet
and all transactions are protected as
the wallet parses call data showing you
what's happening in a user-friendly
manner it supports hundreds of tokens
across a bunch of networks like ethereum
BNB chain polygon and more so you can
use it to store send and receive crypto
it even supports secure backup to Apple
iCloud so you can install the app on
another device to get access over iCloud
and you can easily import wallets by
scanning a private keystring or seed
phrase within your camera app which it's
incredibly simple and easy so go ahead
and check out the one inch wallet by
using the links in the description below
now getting into the display differences
the first thing that stands out
instantly is the difference in bezels
the s23 has Slimmer bezels by a lot look
how thick these ones are on the iPhone
14. and the nice thing about the s23 is
that it actually has the same display
that you get on the s23 ultra which
means that you have up to 1750 Peak knit
brightness compared to only 1200 Peak on
the iPhone 14 and even in terms of the
typical brightness that you would use
all the time the iPhone 14 only goes up
to 800 compared to around a thousand on
the s23 but you only notice that
difference on darker Pages because when
the full screen is white the s23 does
dim it down a little bit compared to the
peak now in terms of the actual display
quality they're both 6.1 inch oleds but
the iPhone does have a slight resolution
boost 2.5 k compared to 2.3 on the s23
and now the final point is the most
important because the iPhone 14 only has
a 60 hertz display which is a deal
breaker for me because I'm used to
promotion on the 14 pro model so I would
never buy a 60 hertz phone like this and
the s23 of course has 120 hertz adaptive
refresh rate support this kills it into
terms of the display and now playing HDR
video on YouTube the s23 is absolutely
smoking the iPhone it's getting brighter
everything looks better more colorful
huge difference in HDR I mean right here
the iPhone 14 just looks so flat so in
terms of overall display quality the s23
just destroys the iPhone and now I'm
really curious to hear the speaker
difference because this is something
that matters a lot to me so let's hear
it
[Music]
and wow surprisingly the iPhone 14
actually sounds a lot better it's louder
the brights are sharper the bass seems a
little bit deeper as well where the s23
is a little bit more muted and kind of
more Punchy instead of having deep bass
so the iPhone wins here and now let's
get into performance starting off with
geekbench 5. yes I said five because
there is the six which is more real
world but I want to test both of them so
let's start with geekbench 5. now the
big deal with the iPhone 14 is that
unlike the 14 pro we have the old a15
bionic chip not the new a16 now however
we do get the five core version of the
a15 which is great for the GPU test but
it is a little bit disappointing on the
s23 we have the brand new Snapdragon 8
Gen 2 which is the same as you get with
the ultra so no sacrifice there and the
final difference is that the s23 has
eight gigs of RAM compared to six on the
iPhone 14 so let's run the CPU Benchmark
and wow I was not expecting this to
happen the s23 is actually faster in
terms of the multi-core score is 4.6
faster but the iPhone is still better in
terms of single core 11 faster wow I was
not expecting an Android device to beat
an iPhone chip now keep in mind this is
the old geekbench 5. now let's test the
new geekbench 6 which the developers
said is much more realistic because
they're changing the way they do
multi-core to make it actually be real
world so let's go ahead and run the CPU
test and there you go geekbench 6 is
done and now the iPhone with the old a15
chip is faster than the brand new
Snapchat Dragon 8 Gen 2 in multi-core 5
faster and then in single core it got
even faster than before 15 faster than
the s23 Chip And now let's get into
comparing the graphics performance with
the first test being gfx bench
specifically the 1440p Aztec Ruins High
tier off-screen test so that way the
refresh rate does not mess with it let's
run it and wow that's actually a big
difference but before I show you guys
that I've got to talk about this the
magic sand case from our partner case Q
which basically combines the best and
most Wanted aspects of a case into one
you've not only got a great and durable
design with strong Max safe magnets
built in but the magsafe ring is
literally on a hinge so you can use it
as a finger grip or a 40 to 120 degree
stand and the best part is that it folds
back completely flush with the case so
it doesn't interfere with any other save
Chargers or accessories so check out the
link in all the discount info in the
video description below the s23's
Graphics in this in this test is 26
faster 60 FPS compared to 47 so it is a
better gaming device according to this
test but let's also run 3dmarks Wildlife
extreme test and there you go Wildlife
extreme unlimited let's run and whoa we
got the scores and the s23 is 41
faster than the iPhone 22.6 FPS compared
to 16. that is a big difference so I'd
say overall the s23 is better in terms
of performance especially because of
that Graphics being so powerful and now
I do want to mention the actual speed of
web browsing or the snappiness which
depends on the real world single core
performance so let's go ahead and run
this test and what in the world the s23
only got 87 runs per minute compared to
342 on the iPhone which is a lot better
so this looks a little bit suspect to me
so I'm going to run it on the San
Samsung web browser and look at that 131
better but still way behind the iPhone
so I think it's just Safari on the
iPhone being insanely optimized to work
with this chip because Apple makes both
the iPhone and the chip the software
everything while Samsung just makes the
device and they have to rely on Qualcomm
and optimization stuff so that's why
we're seeing the difference and now one
thing you're probably noticing right now
is the always on display on the s23
which is awesome I love it and the
iPhone 14 does not have it which is a
big disappointment in fact I actually
had a friend who asked how to turn on is
always on display on his iPhone 14. I
had to tell him bad news because it's
only on the pro and now in terms of the
battery the s23 has one that's 19 larger
however because of iOS optimization the
iPhone actually gets a little bit better
battery life and the s23 does support 25
watt charging instead of 20 on the
iPhone and the advantages don't stop
there for the the s23 because it
supports Wi-Fi 6E instead of 6 and
Bluetooth 5.3 instead of 5.0 so even
better and now let's finally get into
the cameras and once again you can see
the extra telephoto lens on the s23 and
as you can see it greatly improves Zoom
detail shots and as far as the main
camera the iPhone still has the regular
12 megapixel sensor it doesn't get the
48 megapixel from the pro compared to a
50 megapixel sensor on the s23 so the
detail is just so much better especially
if you're cropping in and as far as the
ultra wide camera it's 12 megapixel on
both as well as 12 on the selfie cameras
so let us know which one you think does
better in those shots down below now of
course specs don't mean that much so to
test it out we're actually going to be
doing a blind camera comparison where
I'm going to take a bunch of photos with
both of these phones including the pixel
7 Pro and we're gonna have Max and
Angelica see which one they like better
completely blind so subscribe so you
don't miss out on that video and now to
answer the original question does the
Galaxy s23 destroy the iPhone 14 and
I've gotta say that yes it absolutely
does they're both the same price but you
get so many more features with the s23
you get a better display you get the
always on display feature you get 120
hertz refresh rate you get a chip that's
faster especially for graphics you get
much better cameras you get modern
Wireless specs you just get a much
better phone especially the USB C Port
so I would say definitely buy the s23
over the iPhone and if you're looking at
this thing just go for the 14 pro or
even the 13 Pro which is better than
this one so that is what I think about
this comparison let me know what you
thought down in the comments section
below and definitely click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]